[Music]
well hello it's uh honor to meet you
especially after just playing through uh
sonic frontiers uh both myself as well
as dave behind the camera i think like
the big questions on everyone's mind is
like so what inspired this idea to take
sonic to such a large open world like
traditionally sonic is very like either
2d levels or if it is 3d it's a bit more
linear in scope so this feels like a
pretty big departure for a sonic game
yeah as you did mention there's uh in
sonic's history we've had the 2d side
scrolling gameplay we've had the 3d more
linear format where you have sonic
starting someplace and going to a goal
kind of on a track
this is going to be kind of the next
iteration this is like the future of
sonic is we wanted to make something
that really
embraced freedom and the freedom to kind
of run around wherever you want uh and
and that's what they did with this huge
3d environment is
taking that sonic platform action into
this new 3d environment the iteration
that went into it the passion that went
into it this is the open zone format
that they've created sonic has a bit
more moves in this game than he does uh
in the past and so i was wondering like
early on like most of the enemies i
encountered i'm like oh i can use my
homing attack and kind of take them out
in one hit very traditional sonic but uh
does combat become a bit uh more central
more focused like later on in the game
does that like play a larger role in the
environment in the game that you're
going to be doing
so yeah in this open zone format we also
we have a lot of platforming that people
can enjoy the 3d action platforming we
also have the battle as one of the
elements that people can enjoy in the
open zone format and really we wanted to
make sure we're allowing the player
we're giving the player choice so they
can choose to if they just want to do
action platforming if they run into an
enemy that they don't want to fight they
can also just run away and they don't
have to engage but if you're into battle
and you want to do battle you can also
engage that enemy defeat that enemy and
then go find new enemies to do battle
with so it's really this uh encouraging
people to choose what they want to do
and giving them the freedom to go and do
what they want to do
but if you do want to engage enemies in
battle we also found you know we need a
battle system to
allow people to engage in the enemies
and allow people to kind of
figure out how they want to defeat the
enemies and how they want to have a fun
time with the battle system awesome
and going off of this this choice of
whether or not you want to run a
platform or fight like there are there
are like these roadblocks like in the
world where it's like oh you need this
amount of keys or gears to like get past
this certain thing could someone
theoretically like get through the
entire game like just doing the combat
stuff if they wanted to or just doing
the platforming if they wanted to or
were you going to have to get like a
healthy mixture at some point
so the game design is kind of built with
the idea that most people are going to
want to do both they will want to do
some platform actioning they will want
to do some battle
so it is constructed in that way but it
is also
flexible enough to allow people if they
want to just like i don't want to do a
lot of battle they can find different
ways of getting all the items that they
need to get to continue on with the game
without engaging in too much battle and
the same with platform action if they
don't want to do too much platform
action there are other ways in the game
to collect items that you need to get
you to that next uh stage
uh in order to come continue forward
with the game awesome and just to clear
off everything with the combat i did
notice that there were ways to upgrade
like sonic's attack power and defense
things that haven't really existed in a
sonic game before so how exactly does
that work because in previous games it's
like oh sonic gets hit he loses his
rings you have to collect it again so
what happens if you upgrade your defense
in this game
so because battle is one of the three
key pillars of the game we want to make
sure uh
if you're having problems with battle
maybe you're not you're getting hit and
taking too much damage or your damage
you when you're hitting the enemies
you're not damaging them enough we want
to allow people to kind of upgrade sonic
and change the uh like parameters of
offense and defense and ways of engaging
in the battle so it's more suited to
your style of doing battle
that is part of you know making sure the
battle system is fun and is something
that people can enjoy and experience at
the
levels or at the skill set and
techniques that they have but we also
want to make it easier
maybe if you're not good at battles in
general other ways of kind of improving
sonic and allowing you to maybe get
somewhere that you couldn't get to do
before get the items that you need to
get in order to progress so it's not
just you have to battle and here's the
ways to battle the demo that dave and i
played it gave a very good idea of like
what the gameplay for this is going to
be like but what about narrative what
does transforming this game into such
this large open world does for an error
because sonic's not just oh going
through a level and then having a chance
to talk to tails and knuckles and amy
for like a cut scene before going on to
the next mission like how does the
narrative changer evolve for a game like
this
yeah we did put a lot of focus on
the story and the story presentation in
previous sonic titles
it was kind of like eggman does
something bad oh my gosh i can't believe
this we got to go this stop eggman
because he's doing this thing and it's
very like directly presented to you uh
that's kind of the previous way that
sonic title storytelling kind of took
place and we're changing that format and
we're now putting sonic on this
mysterious island who's on this island
what are the even the end are these
enemies i don't know what am i supposed
to do here how do i save my like these
are all the the mysteries and the
questions that we're presenting people
that we want them to go out and kind of
explore and learn about and have this
experience and figure out in the
storytelling like we have mysteries we
don't know what's going on sonic doesn't
know what's going on either you have to
go out and figure this out and it's this
different style of storytelling that we
that is going to be new i would say even
even though with this like uh underlying
mystery that's going on like is is it
still funny like sonic as a franchise is
pretty usually comical in nature
so yeah if we were to talk about the
storytelling for sonic frontiers it's
probably not so much comical and
probably more mysterious and i know we
have had a lot of comical games in the
past but the the mystery is really where
they're going for frontiers uh that
being said we have employed ian flynn
who is a comic book writer to write a
lot of the dialogue for this game uh and
ian flynn you know is great at that
sonic voice and he's done a great job of
writing dialogue that still feels very
much like you know
a kind of a cynical or kind of snarky
comment comment that sonic would say uh
that's definitely in there so even
though the presentation is mysterious it
is still very true to like what a sonic
fan would enjoy and what sonic fans like
about sonic and uh to continue on for
the story like how how much of it is new
like playing a sonic obviously and we
did see a cut scene that had eggman in
it but
and then there was a mention of amy via
one of the items is is that it are there
new characters for sonic to meet and
interact with uh do we get to see any of
the like the og cast like making the
return in this game
can't say too much about the story again
it's mysterious we don't want to spoil
it for you guys um so we don't want to
talk too much about that but we're on a
mysterious island there's gonna be
mysterious characters mysterious enemies
uh who they are what are they doing
there what's the end goal what's sonic's
supposed to do about all of this those
are the things that we want to present
to people so they can really enjoy the
story and start learning more about all
these characters and enemies and what's
going on while you're doing this and
trying to figure out what's going on
there's these like smaller mysteries
these puzzles like throughout the world
that you have to solve and dave and i
like putting our heads together solved
like the ones in the beginning of the
game pretty like easily but uh we were
wondering like
like how how complex do like these
puzzles get like are there any like true
like uh brain scratchers in there that
are gonna take fans like a while to like
figure out
we really wanted to make sure there are
other fun things to do while on the
island so yes platforming platform
actioning is fun but while you're on the
island there's also these puzzles to do
so for people who want to do that and
choose to do that and have a fun time
that's a great way that they can earn
rewards and kind of do things on the
island that they are having a fun time
with so we do have puzzles on the island
for players to engage with and have fun
with
but we also don't want to force people
to do anything so if you don't want to
do puzzles you don't have to do puzzles
you can still find other ways of having
fun on the island in that open zone and
still progressing in the game and
progressing the story to wrap things up
my co-workers would hate me if i didn't
ask this question but this is sonic
sonic's got to go fast has anyone in the
office like tested to see like how long
it takes for sonic to like run from one
side of the map like all the way to the
other like can can you do it like really
quickly
this is actually a real really great
thing that they're testing in
development when they started making
this game everyone was running from
start to finish you know how quickly can
you clear the island uh from one you
know side to the other uh they were
constantly testing it because sonic is
such a fast character when we're
building this open zone area
if you're going through it too quick
like that doesn't work for the open zone
format so they're you know they'd like
they'd make the island they'd run across
it they're like this is no good throw it
out we got to make it bigger we got to
make it bigger even bigger and they're
constantly testing the size of the
island and constantly questioning
themselves because they have such a fast
character and they need to make the open
zone format a fun playground to play in
that was always what development was you
know iterating on and making sure is the
island too big
it's really not big enough is what they
kept figuring out uh and they had to
keep expanding so they could make that
open zone format awesome uh thank you
for taking the time to talk to me today
and answer all my questions uh yeah for
all of you watching at home uh keep it
here at gamespot we got plenty more
content for summer game fast on the
horizon talk to you later
you